and one's success and the grand prize is
a hot woman women want success what is
the prize for that success someone
talking success like in a career-wise a
lot of money and lonely usually usually
an empty apartment but a lot of money to
spend and that's not doesn't sit well
with you I mean I think people are free
to choose what they want to choose if
that's what you want to do go do it like
but I I think a lot of women do that and
they chase the bag and they chase the
career and then they find themselves
alone at 50 60 and it's not fun and I
think a lot of older women lie to
younger women about this and that's what
rubs me the wrong way that's why I do
what I do